this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 16,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill by the time we reach
our 80s our hearts have beat over 3.3
billion times and have pumped 250
million litres of blood around the body
enough blood to fill 100 Olympic size
pools just three weeks after conception
the first muscle cells of the heart
begin to contract and don't stop until
the moment we die
it is quite frankly a marvel that our
hearts can last so long pick up a stress
ball and see how long you can squeeze it
before your arm starts to cramp attire
unlike skeletal muscle cardiac muscle
has much higher numbers of mitochondria
which provide the vital energy needed
for contractions and with a rich supply
of blood and never has to worry about
the build-up of lactic acid from working
when deprived of oxygen but just because
they do not fatigue does not mean they
are invincible heart disease is one of
the leading causes of death in the world
as we grow older some parts of her heart
can deteriorate and cause some problems
but we have developed some incredible
technology that has extended our lives
one of the most common implants in the
world being pacemakers small implantable
devices that keep our hearts beating
when our natural systems need some help
before seeing how they are implanted and
how they work let's first see how our
own bodies have been engineered by
nature to keep our blood flowing the
heart has two sides separated by an
inner wall called a septum the right
side of the heart which on this diagram
is on the left pumps blood to the lungs
where it is oxygenated and then travels
back to the heart where it is pumped by
the left side to the rest of the body
the walls of the left side are much
thicker and stronger because it has to
pump blood around the entire body
whereas the right side just has to pump
to the lungs and back the heart consists
of four chambers the left and right
ventricles and the left and right atria
the atria and ventricles are separated
by valves at the start of the heartbeat
all four chambers are relaxed and the
valves are open blood flows into the
heart from large veins and the heart
reaches max capacity just here there are
a bundle of cells called a sinoatrial
node that are capable of producing an
electric impulse that will travel
through the heart and cause it to
contract in a specific order first the
impulse travels to the AV node located
here where it triggers both atria to
contract squeezing blood out of the
adrià into the left and right
integrals the electric impulse has now
traveled down through the heart the
fiber is located in the ventricle walls
that now caused them to contract as the
pressure rises it forces these valves to
shut and prevents blood from flowing
backwards you can see each of these
stages on the classic electrocardiogram
the first little bump is the atria
contracting followed by the spike of the
stronger ventricles contracting and
finally there is another little bump as
the ventricles recover foremost this
sequence of events goes unnoticed
thousands of times a day but some may
need a little help controlling their
heartbeat sometimes the sinoatrial node
ability to set the correct pacing breaks
down leading to slower heartbeats or
long pauses between heartbeats
and there are a range of issues while
you may need help and this is why the
incredible pacemaker was invented and as
with most medical inventions it started
as an incredibly dangerous and scary
device the first being invented by
Albert s Hyman in the 1930s it consisted
of a hand cranked spring motor which
would store the hand crank rotation as
potential energy in a spring this spring
motor then drove a generator with these
large u-shaped magnets providing the
magnetic flux needed to degenerate the
direct current voltage the current was
then pulsed by a rotating interrupter
disk with four conducting paths which
intermittently made contact with a brush
which supplied this huge needle
electrode amazingly this little machine
was portable but approved ineffective
due to the low voltage output his work
was ultimately abandoned but other
researchers recognized its potential
after the Second World War a method of
inducing hypothermia by cooling the
heart until it stopped beating to allow
to be worked on during surgery was being
investigated but upon rewarming it was
found that the heart needed help with
controlling heart rate as metabolic
function recovered and jaane hops
developed this device for the job
delivering impulses at the desired rate
through paddles that were placed inside
the chest cavity during surgery near the
sinoatrial note the potential of using
such a device on patients suffering from
heart defects at normal temperatures was
soon realized but repeated applications
of high voltages caused muscle pain and
twitches along with burns making it
unsuitable for extended use what we
needed was an implantable device hops
developed the catheter electrode which
removed the need for open chest
surgeries bypassing the electrodes
through the subclavian vein and into the
hearse on Halloween night 1957 a power
outage struck a Minneapolis hospital
leaving several young patients without
pacing from the mains-powered pacemakers
killing one of the children and pushing
famed heart surgeon dr. C Walton
Lillehei to request the hospital's
technician Earl Bakken to develop a
battery-powered pacemaker he returned
with this device a wearable pacemaker
powered by mercury batteries that would
launch Earl Boykins company Medtronic
into the fortune 500 this was a
revolutionary device but the need to
pass the wires through the skin was a
constant infection risk what was needed
was a fully implantable device and with
the continual improvements to
transistors allowing for the
miniaturization of circuitry and
improvements to batteries this was soon
realized this was the first-ever fully
implantable pacemaker created unemployed
in Sweden to save Erna Larson's life
with a rechargeable nickel kadian
battery which was charged through this
induction coil overnight about once a
month it's utilized some of the first
silicon transistors imported into sweden
allowing it to use less energy over
older germanium transistors all this was
encapsulated in a biocompatible epoxy
resin Arnaud Larsen survived 286 with
his pacemaker being replaced a total of
25 times over the course of his life as
the technology improved incrementally
current generation pacemakers are now
smaller and more reliable than ever
Medtronic have even developed the
world's smallest pacemaker which is
implanted directly into the right
ventricle without any cables and
eliminating the need for the pacemaker
to be implanted under the skin which can
lead to discomfort over 700,000
pacemakers are implanted worldwide every
year these devices help people live
healthier happier lives and have
advanced so far that money can
practically forget that they suffer from
heart disease this subject is something
I spent four years studying to work with
and I've worked in the medical device
industry in the past with Medtronic I am
however completely self-taught in
illustration and animation I designed
this logo over three years ago and today
I'm happy to unveil the new updated
version which someone who actually knows
what they're doing designed I
essentially just traced the gear-tooth
and attempted to make it look like the
font I was using with no real design
experience
I may have fared better with making it
look professional if I watch some of
these skills share classes on logo
design first they teach simple things
about shape type and color which I just
had no idea about at the time something
as simple as fixing the symmetry of
height and width of my logo has done
wonders and that's the type of thing
this course will teach you these days
you can teach yourself pretty much any
skill online and scho share is a
fantastic place to do it with
professional and understandable classes
that follow a clear learning curve you
can dive in and start learning how to do
the work you love a premium membership
begins around ten dollars a month for
unlimited access to all courses but the
first 1,000 people to sign up with this
link will get their first two months for
free I so ask yourself right now what
skill have you been putting off learning
what project have you been dreaming of
completing but aren't sure if you've the
skills to do it why not start right now
and sign up disco share using the link
below to get your first two months for
free you've nothing to lose an a
valuable life skill to gain as usual
thanks for watching and thank you to all
my patreon supporters if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my Twitter
Facebook discord server subreddit and
Instagram pages are below